Want to start your own VTuber Agency?
Don't!
But if you insist, then here's stuff I wish I knew beforehand or was realistic about before
starting operations.
1. Make sure before you start ordering artworks or assets that you have fully fleshed out
reference sheets of your VTubers or else you will constantly be going back and forth with
artists for fixes. That's time and money wasted when it could have been done right the first time.
2. Make sure you have the money to burn.
Whatever cost you estimated in your head, double it then add some more.
Vealor's original budget was $30,000 USD.
The reality, double it and add some more.
3. Do not expect unrealistic things from your talents.
You have to enable your talents so helping with clipping, video ideas,
submitting ideas means your talents can achieve their dreams.
And most of all, check what your talents internet speeds are.
Most likely someone is still on dial up.
Hmm.